[Music]
how many times have you wished you had a
kitchen gadget that would make your life
just a little bit easier or maybe you're
just tired of the same old same old and
need to spice things up in the kitchen
here's the good news the cool kitchen
gadgets you're looking for probably
exists Pizza Scissors pen cake pen it's
time to take your cooking skills to the
next level if you liked our video make
sure you click that red subscribe button
now join us as we explore some of the
coolest kitchen gadgets you absolutely
need in your life apple core and slicer
let's start with one of the best new
kitchen inventions on the market the
Apple slicers are probably one of the
things that everyone needs it's now such
a common kitchen gadget you can pretty
much find it in any store although there
are people out there who would eat an
apple with their core most of us prefer
having them perfectly sliced and that's
exactly what this little handy gadget
will do split your Apple in two
beautifully even pieces and remove its
core without any issues but you don't
have to stop at Apple's an apple slicer
can also be used for potatoes or any
other fruit or vegetable that needs to
be cut up quickly and precisely looking
for something fanciers in the slicer
check out it's apple and potato peeler
that lets you cut your apples into
beautiful swirls
is this really a must-have absolutely
don't forget an apple a day keeps the
doctor away egg separator using eggs in
the kitchen isn't always as simple not
everyone masters the act of eggs
separating it takes time and skill and
if you're cooking with kids you're
guaranteed a huge mess this is where egg
separators come in and whoever thought
of this kitchen gadget is a complete
genius the concept is simple easily
separate your egg yolks from life
without having to juggle them between
two shelves check out this cool egg
separator called yolk out it's a simple
silicone bulb that sucks up the entire
yolk and leaves the egg whites behind in
your
just squeeze it and let it suck up the
egg yolk and repeat the process as many
times as you like we also love the
boogieman yolk separator people have
also created some really clever DIY egg
separators all you need to do is find an
empty bottle of water and squeeze it to
suck in the egg yolk this is a perfect
trick to let your kids help you out with
baking cupcakes prepare breakfast
without making a huge mess with broken
shells or letting egg yolk accidentally
run out on your kitchen floor separating
your eggs has never been easier their
calm meat handler the days of pulling
your pork or chicken with fork are over
it's time to upgrade those Forks to
something much more convenient meet
their pom meat handlers their heat
resistant and dishwasher safe their main
mission is to pull pork
and to shred chicken but you can also
use them to talk salads lift the turkey
and much more they were featured on
America's Test Kitchen and BBQ
pitmasters and our favorite meat
handling gadget you can also use them to
stabilize any item as you cut it or
simply just to look a bit more powerful
when cooking meals they're popular with
cooks as they're easy to use and get the
job done without any foods sticking on
to them after pulling pork or chicken
using a fork in the a tedious task but
the Bearpaw meat handlers make the job a
lot easier you can also upgrade them to
the claws made from stainless steel for
even more precise shredding they've been
praised for saving a lot of time when it
comes to cooking and amazon.com reviewer
claims that a large shredding job that
usually took 45 minutes can be easily
done in just 5 with these Bearpaw meat
handlers pineapple slicer peeling a
pineapple takes a lot of time and how to
cut and peel a pineapple is a commonly
googled question so it's no wonder
pineapple lovers welcome this little
gadget with open arms meet the
three-in-one tools it's a pineapple
slicer that also peels and cores an
entire pineapple in a matter of seconds
the process is pretty simple it works
just like a corkscrew and
pineapple circles you can just pull out
and throw in a fruit salad or eat on the
phone after a few seconds of twisting
the cutter into the fruit the entire
flesh of the pineapple will come out
without a problem once you remove the
flesh you can also just easily drink the
remaining pineapple juice in the shell
no more buying already cut up pineapple
that can be awfully expensive this handy
little gadget will save you plenty of
time and create delicious pineapple
filled snacks and breakfasts in no time
heated toast knife this product is for
all fans of The Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy what is breakfast without
toast but what happens when you don't
have the spare time to cut the toast and
put it in the toaster and let's not talk
about the times you've burnt the toast
and have to repeat the process all over
again Colin Furze a British inventor
decided it was time to put the breakfast
struggles to an end
he created a heat toasted knife that can
cut and toast all at the same time he
initially created it using a modified
microwave transformer that connects to a
knife with cables as soon as you turn on
the transformer the knife gets heated
pretty quickly making it easy to slice
that toast in no time
while colin claims this knife is very
easy to make we have yet to find a
participant
however you can purchase this heated
butter knife at self warming and
transmits heat directly from your hand
butter on toast anyone watermelon corner
and slicer if an apple corer isn't your
thing but you're really craving a
watermelon this next products perfect
for you tired of cutting up watermelon
into smaller pieces just so you could
get to every bit of the flesh and let's
not talk about the mess you can leave
behind after cutting a watermelon this
watermelon slicer might make the job
easier for you it comes with razor-sharp
blades to easily slice through the
watermelon and transport it into a
bowler plate the juices remain in the
shell and go nowhere near your kitchen
counters all you need to do is slice
through the watermelon and grab each
piece repeat the process until you're
only left with the show perfect for
summer parties birthday
or just healthy breakfast not sure how
to cut a watermelon use the bearclaw's
we mentioned earlier to help you
stabilize the watermelon as you slice
through it now you have everything you
need to be ready for summer
avocado slicer who doesn't love avocados
but we bet you struggled scooping
avocados and removing their skin split
pit and scoop is the manifesto of this
next product an avocado slicer is what
every avocado lover needs in their
kitchen coming with three functions in a
single gadget this is a simple tool to
help you get to that delicious avocado
every morning all you have to do is
split the avocado by slicing it with the
sharp blade at the end and open it up
then you use the middle pinning tool to
remove the pit by simply placing and
twisting no more digging that thing out
with a knife or a spoon and losing the
precious avocado flesh in the process
after you're done with pitting all you
need to do is scoop out your avocado use
the scoop on the other end place it on
the avocado and just simply drag across
not only will you scoop it out but you
will also cut your avocado into even
pieces all you need now is some eggs and
toast and your breakfast is served pizza
scissors warning
you'll want pizza after watching this
part of the video if you've ever made
homemade pizza and have children you
know they will go after the biggest
pizza slice they can because of this
they leave uneven pieces to the rest of
the family pizza wheels usually don't
help with creating even pieces you can
fairly split between your friends and
family not to mention your toppings
usually get dragged off and leave you
with the dough and some tomato sauce
these unique pizza scissors might stop
this problem and yes you heard that
right
they're scissors but for pizza they come
with an attached keeps a spatula at the
bottom so all you need to do is slide it
under your pizza slice it repeat the
process on the other side and list
a perfect pizza slice it might feel
wrong using scissors on your pizza but
trust us this
although you probably won't see any
famous pizza maker use scissors to cut
their pizza it's definitely a life hack
to make your culinary life just a bit
easier time to order some pizza and buy
scissors bottle size ice cubes everyone
carries around a water bottle right but
unless you put your bottle in the fridge
you'll usually be stuffed with
room-temperature water because your ice
cubes are just too big to fit this can
be particularly annoying for anyone
who's involved in any kind of Fitness
and constantly drinks from a water
bottle it's hard to stay refresh and
cool down when your water reaches its
normal temperature well this isn't a
problem anymore
check out these perfectly sized ice
cubes you can easily slide in your water
bottle ice cube molds are always
creative but this is one of the most
practical molds we have ever seen fill
them with water stick them in the
freezer and use them in your water
bottle the next day it turns out they're
not just useful for ice and water
bottles many have started using them for
recycling broken crayons making candy
and much much more
how fun what would you like to try doing
with this mold pancake pen one of our
favorite products on this list is a
pancake pen one of the simplest tools
with absolutely magical effects your
pancakes will never be the same again
these dispensers can hold three cups of
pancake batter and have a silicon tip
they're absolutely perfect to create
pancakes in some of the funniest shapes
numbers letters objects and more it's
such a popular tool even artists are
taking advantage of it you've probably
heard a pancake art before right well
some people are really taking it to the
next level and creating some of the most
outstanding pancake shapes they're
almost too pretty to be actually eaten
check out these Pixar characters and the
cool Easter Bunny pancake if pancake
pens aren't your thing you can also
easily make just about any pancake shape
using silicone pancake holes it's one of
the best ways to make your breakfast
creative and
what's your favorite kitchen gadget from
this list do you have any culinary DIY
tips let us know in the comments below
and don't forget to like this video want
more check out our video on 10 simple
life hacks that could save you a lot of
trouble see you next time
[Music]